so with age of Ultron issue number nine
we're going to get this sort of piecing
together of events this idea of the
alternate row that Wolverine could have
taken had he actually decided to use the
advice that was given to him by Tony
Stark in the alternate reality now
before we get too far into the story I'm
gonna let you guys know ahead of time
this story is going to get confusing as
so I'm going to do what I can to
try to try to explain it as best I can
to keep it as simple as possible so what
we see is we start this story is that
for the most part the helicarrier's have
already crashed into New York City and
New York City is almost totally
destroyed the immediate vicinity where
the helicarrier's are crashed is
virtually in shambles but in addition to
this almost all the superheroes the
defenders and most everybody who is part
of this conflict is dead but as we see
Wolverine is one of the only individuals
who's able to escape and he's able to
get out of the rubble from here we
switch to about five days later and
Wolverines leg has completely healed
itself an easy repair as he prepares to
to walk away to move away he's attacked
by a couple doombots indicating to us
that over the course of this five days
that Morgana lafay has successfully been
able to take over at this half of the
world and so most likely she takes over
the entire world now we don't really
know what happens with her after this we
don't know if she even survived the
conflict where she was killed in the
process but as things begin to move
forward we see that of course Wolverine
is able to easily overpower and destroy
these doombots due to of course his
adamantium claws in addition to his
accelerated healing factor and so for
the most part the do bots aren't really
able to do much against him but after
he's able to successfully destroy the
doom bots he again continues to walk
away but he's grabbed by Tony Stark and
Tony Stark asks him he asked him whether
or not a person like Hank hem could make
so much of a difference if he was his
existence would really be able to change
the world entirely to make it something
other than what it is right now and so
he tells Wolverine that he knows he's
going to try to travel back in time and
to stop himself from killing Hank Pym he
knows he's going to try to fix his
mistake but that he can't do that and
the reason why
is because time again is not this
indestructible thing time is not this
absolute construct time as he explains
it is a living organism that while it
doesn't necessarily have sentience it
doesn't really walk around and move
around the time is part of everything
it's part of all life and that it can
bend and it can break and that if
Wolverine keeps manipulating time too
much that he'll tear it and he'll
destroy time entirely and the question
would become what would happen if time
didn't exist anymore what would happen
if it came to an end because the
individuals who would be affected here
would not just be wool rain and Tony
Stark and the other earthbound heroes
that it would be the universe as a whole
indicating to us that is quite possible
that the ramifications of Wolverines
actions could have an impact on not just
this universe but other universes as
well which of course is something we
will see in that Angela will be brought
to this universe and that Galactus will
be affected by Wolverines actions as
well from here we transition back to the
point in which will rain had initially
encountered Hank Pym and attempted to
kill him and for the sake of this
discussion and what's going to be coming
up we're going to be referring to the
Wolverine as that's wearing gray as the
normal Wolverine and the Wolverine
that's wearing his old uniform as the
classic Wolverine and again I know this
is a little confusing but once the video
begins to wrap up it'll all make sense
and it'll all tie together but again the
normal version of Wolverine has not
killed Hank Pym yet and so of course
he's telling Hank Pym the same thing
that he had told him that he's
transitioning back to the same moment
when he says that Hank Pym had done some
great things in the world that Hank Pym
had done what he could but that in the
end the actions of Hank Pym wiping out
or I guess creating Ultron who in turn
wiped out all life on the planet is
something that just cannot be ignored
and so again
Wolverine prepares to kill Hank hem from
here we transitioned back to Susan storm
who's standing out by the car and soon
as the storm is debating with herself
she's asking what it is that she's doing
out here why is it that she's simply
just waiting she says she can't let this
happen but that the needs of her friends
are also the needs of her own and so the
question that she's debating with
herself is the same debate that her and
Wolverine had previously gotten into
where the issue was which one is more
important than
each of the mini or what it is that she
thinks is right but before she is able
to take any action she's presumably
knocked out by somebody at this point we
transition back to the normal Wolverine
as he's fighting and attempting to kill
Hank him but again before he's able to
engage too much further before he's able
to actually deal a killing blow to hank
pym somebody yell stop and when they
turn around we see the Wolverine that
had initially jumped forward and killed
Hank him the first time and again we're
going to refer to him as classic
Wolverine and classic Wolverine tells
normal Wolverine that this isn't going
to work that hank pym dying is not going
to fix the problem that when hank pym
dies that his creates a reality that's
just as bad if not worse than the
reality that the normal wolverine had
left in an attempt to kill hank pym in
order to fix it and what a normal
Wolverine believes is that perhaps this
is some kind of a ruse that perhaps this
is some kind of a joke but classic will
rain tells a normal Wolverine to stand
down he says that this is not some kind
of a ruse so this is him coming to him
to try to tell him what it is this going
to happen what is this going to take
place if he engages in this action
classic Wolverine also tells Hank Pym
that this is exactly what it looks like
that moon Wolverine had come there in an
attempt to kill him and that with his
death he had hoped that Ultron by virtue
of having never been created would cease
to exist
and that the future would be fixed but
normal Wolverine asks classic Wolverine
who it was that sent him if it was
Captain America if perhaps he's there on
Ultron's orders but classic Wolverine
tells normal Wolverine that is the
outfit that he's currently wearing is
the only outfit that was brought with
him but that the whole purpose of him
being here is to try to keep a normal
Wolverine from killing Hank Pym and what
classic Wolverine does is he gives
normal Wolverine a I guess a some kind
of proof that he is really Wolverine he
simply just tells him 1928 Sharleen
Baumgartner and this seems to be some
kind of proof that seems to be some kind
of evidence to indicate that classic
wolverine is really will rain and that
the two of them are existing in the same
time and so no more rain begins to
listen he begins to pay attention to
what it is is going on and he asked
classic Wolverine what it is that they
should do and of course he offers a few
suggestions he says maybe they should
kill
another time maybe they should go back
and kill him as a baby but for the most
part classic Wolverine says no he says
that hank pym has to exist that hank pym
has to live that he has to create Ultron
and he says that Tony Stark had given
him some kind of an idea something about
possibly creating a virus but for the
most part Hank Pym is very shocked to
see all of this taking place he's amazed
to know that that this this is the
Wolverine knows who Tony Stark Stark is
he's amazed to know that he of course is
an Avenger when he claims to have been
an Avenger is really interesting for
Hank him to watch this thing unfold to
learn the time-travel does exist and for
the most part we see that Hank Pym says
okay he says that if the future comes to
a very dark point if the future elite is
led to a place where by Ultron is able
to conquer the world then he simply
won't make Ultron but classic Wolverine
says no he says that everything that has
ever happened up until the point when he
first went back in time has to happen
that all those things have to take place
otherwise the universe could end up with
all of reality could end up in a much
worse place than it is right now and so
again the question is asked does it mean
that Ultron has to be created and that
if Ultron is going to mop the floor with
them then why should Hank Pym create
Ultron in the first place but again the
classic Wolverine says that some kind of
time release virus can be installed an
Ultron some kind of time release virus
can be made so that when Ultron attempts
to take over the world the first time
that this virus can be activated and
that Ultron won't actually come to power
but for the most part we again see both
of these Wolverines debating with one
another we see both of these Wolverines
again trying to come to terms normal
wolverine still wants to kill Hank Pym
but classic Wolverine is continuing you
to try to convince him that killing Hank
Pym will not fix the world's problems
that it will not make things better
again we see Hank Pym saying that he
knows what he has to do that for the
most part he's now prepared about what
about what will take place he knows that
if Ultron being created is going to lead
to Ultron evolving itself and by virtue
of evolving itself leading multiple
incursions against the Avengers and
against the planet Earth that now
they'll know but again normal over I'm
sorry classic Wolverine says that this
will
work that that Hank pen has to continue
the timeline has to continue as if
everything had simply just functioned
the way it always did and hank pym asks
how he says how is he supposed to do
this house is supposed to achieve and at
this point Susan storm chimes in and
Susan storm says he's going to have to
make himself forget now this would be
something that'll actually happen
outside of Hank Pym it'll happen because
of something he doesn't control but for
the most part Hank Pym is again
surprised to see Susan storm because in
his time and the 1960 Susan storm is
much younger but again the Susan storm
says that for the most part they should
bring Reed Richards in on this they
should get a hold of Reed Richards in
their time because what they can do is
explain to that version of Reed Richards
what it is is taken place and Reed
Richards can help them come to terms
with what's going on help them figure
out a way to solve things but the
classic Wolverine says no classic
Wolverine says that nobody else can know
about this because if anybody else is
aware of this and know in turn be
affected by the actions here and this
has to be a self-contained situation in
order to keep the timeline functioning
the way that it always has and so what
Hank Pym does is the ashlee question how
was this supposed to happen he asked how
is it that he is supposed to create
Ultron knowing that Ultron is going to
challenge and attempt to defeat the
Avengers on multiple occasions possibly
leading to a situation whereby Ultron is
going to take over the world how can he
do this without somehow doing anything
to try to stop Ultron along the way
aside from creating a Time time-related
virus a time-release virus but for the
most part we don't see any kind of
answer this given to him because what we
do is we transition back to Antarctica
back to the Savage Land whereby we have
the classic Wolverine the one who
initially traveled in time in the first
place the noble Wolverine who was the
version that classic Wolverine had
encountered as he traveled back to try
to stop himself from killing Hank Pym
and of course Susan storm and what Susan
storm asks is are they both really going
to come back here are they both really
going to go back to the future and what
classic Wolverine says is no he simply
tells her to give them a minute and so
as the two of them enter the cave
classic Wolverine tells normal Wolverine
that he's seen too many things
that he's seen what happens when hank
pym dies that he's seen all these future
outcomes he's seen what happens when
Morgana lafay takes over the world and
that these are memories that he just
can't live with that he doesn't want to
continue with and so what he does is he
tells normal Wolverine to kill him and
so from here we transition back to Susan
storm and as a normal Wolverine or I
guess the only Wolverine now is walking
out we get this kind of transition we
get this kind of situation where we see
that of course Susan storm is surprised
to see that he killed the other version
of himself but we also see that hank pym
is continuing to work on ultron and for
the most part hank pym is haunted by
this hank pam is really affected by the
idea that he is consciously creating a
robot that could potentially take over
the world and the question that Susan
storm asks is what happens what happens
if hank pym creating a time-release
virus is beyond his abilities what
happens if he creates a time-release
virus and Ultron but somewhere along the
way Ultron becomes conscious of it and
decides to correct it no one really
knows what would go on here a lot of
things are being left up left up to
chance but as a story begins to come to
an end as this comic begins to come to
an end we're left with Ultron as he's
activating itself for the first time and
calling Hank Pym his daddy at this point
we're going to go ahead and bring this
story to in and a hope wasn't too
confusing for you guys if it was let me
know and I'll try to explain a little
bit better but with that being said I
will catch you guys later peace